hello everyone the nord medic here and
in this video we will talk about a
microbe known as the staphylococcus
aureus now staphylococcus belongs to a
group of medically important gram
positive cocky staphylococcal infections
range from the trivial infections to
some life-threatening rapidly fatal
infections
now most prevalent of this genus is
staphylococcus aureus
and it commonly causes food poisoning
and toxic stock syndrome now this video
will be a brief overview of
staphylococcus aureus and uh will serve
as a rapid revision tool for your exams
but if you want an in-depth
understanding of the clinical picture
and laboratory diagnostic algorithms of
staphylococcus aureus i would highly
recommend you to watch the video on
nerdmatic's channel linked over here in
the eye button
now let us understand where the
staphylococcus aureus belongs in the
microbial world
now staphylococcus aureus is a
gram-positive organism so if we do a
gram staining
of a staphylococcal smear it will appear
purple cock-eye so if you don't know
what gram staining is i would recommend
you to watch the video on gram staining
in our channel the link will be in the
description box below now the free
living bacteria can be classified based
on gram staining into gram positive and
gram negative organisms now gram
positive organisms can be round shaped
or cocaine or can be rod shaped or
bacilli now in
gram-positive cocaine we have several
groups like micrococci enterococcus
staphylococcus streptococci and pepto
streptococci now out of them we are
going to focus on the staphylococci now
the three most important medically
relevant
uh staphylococci are staphylococcus
aureus staphylococcus epidermidis and
staphylococcus saprophyticus we will
restrict our discussion in this video to
staphylococcus aureus
now
the features of staphylococcus aureus
under microscope staphylococcus aureus
appears gram-positive that is dark
purple staining uh it appears around
hence known as cockai and occurring
clusters or look like a cluster of
grapes and that's why known as staphylo
and also they
show catalyst positivity and coagulates
positivity and under microscope
originally staphylococci look like this
apart from that staphylococcus aureus is
a faculty of anaerobe that means it
prefers oxygen but can survive without
it also and it has a unique property of
forming something known as a biofilm and
this is responsible for causing the
iv cannula associated
staphylococcal infections
now the capsule that the staphylococcus
aureus produces helps it to evade
phagocytosis
now let us come to the pathogenesis of
staphylococcus aureus
now the stefano the basis of
pathogenicity of staphylococcus aureus
is present in the toxins it produces
says
like the toxic shock syndrome toxin one
the pantone valentine leukocytin toxin
the hemolysin the exfoliating toxin and
enterotoxin
now staphylococcus aureus secretes
exotoxins which affect the blood cells
for example the hemolysin which causes
lysis of rbc and leukocytin which causes
lysis of wbc apart from that it produces
a fibrino nectarine binding protein on
its surface which binds to a fibrino
nectarine present on the extracellular
matrix and helps the staphylococcus to
adhere to the cells and the
extracellular
matrix
now staphylococcus can colonize the skin
and it is present as the normal general
skin microflora but if the skin gets
breached and the staphylococcus can get
the chance to invade your skin they can
arrange
a lot of infections ranging from abscess
impetigo folliculitis or even cellulitis
now in the skin the exfoliating toxin
destroys the dysmobilin one cell
adherence molecule
and causes
scalded skin syndrome
now staphylococcus has on surface a
protein known as a protein a now this
protein a binds to the fc component of
igg and this renders the staphylococcus
and phagocytable because the macrophage
cannot bind to the staphylococcus
anymore and this leads to a
anti-phagocytic effect
now let us come to the diagnosis of
staphylococcus aureus now the lab
diagnosis of staphylococcus aureus
ranges from collection of sample then
uh then
putting it into culture plates and
performing cultures and then doing
microscopy from smears produced from
these cultures and then obviously
performing my biochemical analysis based
on coagulase and catalase
now if you want a detailed understanding
of laboratory diagnosis of sres do check
out the video on sres on nerd medics
youtube channel
in summary we can say that
staphylococcus aureus
is belongs to a group of medically
important gram-positive cocky
staphylococcus aureus are faculty of
anaerobe which can produce biofilms
can cause disease itself or by means of
its toxins diseases range from trivial
skin infections to life-threatening
toxic soft syndrome
i hope you have understood this video
well you can get high quality flash
cards and notes on this topic and many
other topics present on this channel if
you follow us on our instagram or
facebook page at animatedbiology with
urban the link will be in the
description box below also you you can
support us so that we can keep on
creating high quality educational
content for free by contributing on our
patreon page also you can use the super
thanks icon to support our channel on
the bottom right corner of any video and
you can contribute using paytm paypal or
upi
if you wish to connect with urpan of
animated biology with arpan the links
will be in the description box below and
for medicine related content follow nerd
medics youtube channel and the
connection links are given over here
until then bye bye see you in the next
one